the fastest growing small business type
is people that are like becoming content
creators what is the right mindset for
somebody working a nine-to-five job to
start shifting into that self-employed
entrepreneur mindset there's no tax code
that says that you have to be good at
business there is a tax code that says
if you show the intent to generate
income and to treat and operate as a
business now you open the doors to
utilize all of these additional
deductions so as soon as you have the
intention to be self-employed as soon as
you have an idea of the content that you
want to create structure yourself as a
business if you treat something like a
hobby it's going to cost you money like
a hobby but when you treat something
like a business you reap the rewards of
what businesses have to offer